[Música]
[Aplausos]
sabías que en un espacio similar al de
tu baño puedes cultivar suficientes
alimentos para dar de comer a una
familia de cuatro personas durante todo
el año esto es lo que una nano granja
puede lograr por ti y por tu familia sin
contar los beneficios que puede tener a
la salud y en especial al medio ambiente
desde que era muy pequeño siempre tuve
una gran atracción por las plantas y por
la naturaleza y siempre andaba buscando
qué hacer con esa inquietud una de mis
primeras incursiones fue construir en la
azotea de mi casa un huerto vertical que
les dio un gusto enorme a mis papás
cuando destruyó y media azotea y no
creció más que nada porque no creció ni
una plantita chiquita en esa azotea sin
embargo mis padres eran muy felices bah
a lo largo del tiempo sin embargo hubo
una persona que fue mi maestra en todo
esto de las plantas yo le llamaba
abuelita abuelita a mí me solía sentarme
con ella mientras ella regaba las
plantas y las macetas
un calor tremendo en monterrey yo me
sentaba al lado mientras ella me iba
explicando cada planta sus hojas su
color me hablaba de las cochinillas me
hablaba de los de las lombrices y me
dejaba jugar con ellas mientras yo iba
aprendiendo para qué servía cada planta
y qué utilidad podía tener
estoy convencido de que hoy en día la
agricultura y el medio ambiente han ido
cambiando por algo
que ya no es lo mismo la codicia y la
avaricia del hombre ha ido destruyendo
el medio ambiente en pro de poder
cultivar alimentos más grandes más
rápido y en menos tiempo el ser humano
hoy por hoy utiliza pesticidas
utiliza herbicidas e insecticidas que
terminan con cierta parte de las plantas
locales que degradan el suelo y que de
pasada matan a insectos benéficos como
las abejas pero no sólo eso sino que
también hoy por hoy el ser humano
explota a otro ser humano para poder
tener más producción
la pregunta era qué puede hacer un
físico como yo que no sabe absolutamente
nada de agricultura que lo único que
tiene es un gusto por las plantas y nada
más que puede hacer para cambiar esta
situación y entonces me puse a
investigar me puse a estudiar un poco y
fue cuando nació la idea de hacer una
nano granja tener un espacio tan pequeño
en casa donde poder crecer mis propios
alimentos y alimentar también a mi
familia
suena como algo relativamente loco pero
además faltaba algo en mi definición yo
vivía en la ciudad tenía que buscar algo
que hace que se acoplará a la ciudad y
ahí fue cuando nació la idea de una nano
granja urbana un espacio en la casa en
la ciudad donde crecer alimentos estoy
seguro que todos los aquí presentes
tenemos un espacio una esquina un hueco
un cuarto que lo tenemos lleno de
trebejos y lleno de cosas que ya no
utilizamos absolutamente para nada
ese podría ser el espacio ideal para
poder comenzar a cultivar tus propios
vegetales y poder tener que dar de comer
a tu familia de manera más sana
nutritiva y que ya esté libre de
pesticidas que son tóxicos para tu salud
para poder tener una granja todos
tenemos los elementos básicos en casa y
sólo requerimos de cuatro elementos
básicos agua tierra plantas y animales
el agua tenemos casi todos acceso a ella
hoy por hoy y si no lo tuvieras creo que
no es complicado pensar en tener un
recipiente que esté captando un poco de
agua de lluvia para esa utilizarla en tu
propia granja la tierra al contrario del
que suena tan complicado de hacerla es
muy sencillo de hacerla si tú tienes un
reciclador de basura orgánica o lo que
se llama una composta tu puedes juntar
todos los desechos que sacas de tu casa
de tu cocina y ponerlos allí para
empezar a reciclar los una buena
composta puede generar tierra en 18 días
como mac como mínimo con 18 días que
tengas de composta tiene suficiente para
empezar a juntar tierra para empezar a
sembrar tus propias plantas y germinar
tus semillas
las plantas que son unas de las
principales protagonistas en esta
historia
solíamos pensar que eran muy complicadas
de cultivar y que necesitábamos grandes
extensiones de tierra y que
necesitábamos de bueyes y de tractores
para poder orar y poder tenerlas allí y
cultivarlas hoy por hoy sabemos que en
un espacio de 30 centímetros por 30
centímetros en un cuadrado que mide de
lado lo mismo que mide una regla de las
que usamos en la primaria es posible
crecer un cierto número de vegetales y
tener la profundidad que tiene este
celular que son 15 centímetros de
profundidad si tú agregas una buena
composta que esté rica para tus plantas
en un espacio así se puede cultivar una
lechuga se pueden crecer 4 acelgas se
pueden crecer 9 betabeles y hasta 16
rábanos solo en un espacio de 30 por 30
ahora si yo pusiera 4 cuadrados a lo
largo ya lo ancho obtendría un gran
cuadrado que mide poquito más de un
metro
en ese cuadrado cabrían 16 vegetales
distintos la cantidad suficiente para
que una persona tenga ensalada durante
todo el año y si yo tengo 2 cuadrados de
esos está comprobado que se puede
generar suficiente alimento para que esa
persona tenga alimentos tengas vegetales
durante todo el año sin ningún problema
ahora
nos falta uno de los elementos básicos
de la de la granja y sé que me van a
decir que estoy loco si pienso que se
puede tener un animal de granja en casa
sé que muchos de aquí me dirán oye yo
vivo en una casa pequeña yo vivo en una
de interés social y habrá quien me diga
yo vivo en un departamento pues nada más
lejos de la realidad aún en esos
pequeños espacios se pueden tener se
pueden tener animales de granja que sean
suficientes para darnos de comer
quiero hablar solamente de tres animales
que para mí son los reyes de una granja
urbana la primera son mis princesas las
gallinas las gallinitas son aparte de
muy divertidas de estar observando y ver
todas las travesuras que suelen hacer
tienen algunas propiedades que
desconocemos una sola gallina puede
producir entre 300 y 330 huevos en un
año y al contrario de lo que pensamos no
se requiere de un gallo para poder tener
una gallina que produzca un huevo
solo hay que tener cuidado con una cosa
las gallinas si no las cuidan son
rebeldes y hasta pandilleras a las mías
lo único que les faltaba era grafitear
la pared de mi casa pero fuera de eso
destruyeron lo que encontraron
los siguientes en la lista son los
conejos los conejos son muy hermosos
porque a la gran mayoría de los niños
les agradan porque son pachón chiquitos
los acarician etcétera pero lo que me
interesa que sepamos de los conejos es
que una sola pareja de conejos puede
tener hasta 80 crías en un año el
equivalente a que tengas carne de conejo
dos veces por semana durante todo el año
en tu casa una pareja de conejos cabe en
este espacio en un cuadrado no requiere
más si tú tienes dos parejas imagínate
lo que tendrás los terceros en la lista
son los peces los peces al contrario de
lo que pensamos se pueden tener en
espacios reducidos está comprobado que
en un tinaco de tamaño pequeño que son
más o menos de un metro cúbico es decir
un metro para cada metro para ya yo meto
para arriba
puedo tener hasta 100 mojarras de tamaño
mediano
perfectamente comestibles que tengo que
serán totalmente saludables y estarán
listas para dar de comer la
característica que tienen estos tres
animales en conjunto es que los tres se
pueden alimentar de la basura que tú
generas en tu cocina y a cambio de
alimentarse de esa basura que tú generas
en tu cocina ellos van a generar un
excremento que se puede ir a la composta
y puede enriquecer esa tierra que puedes
utilizar para tus vegetales y tener un
alimento todavía más nutritivo y 100%
natural
por si fuera poco quiero decirte que mi
granja hoy por hoy
es un gran ahorro y una fuente de
ingreso mis gallinas se pagan su
alimento ellas solas con la venta del
huevo y el ahorro que hemos logrado
obtener con los vegetales que producimos
por mucho paga el agua que consumimos
para poder regar los pero me interesa
una cosa más decir allí no sólo eso pero
puedo presumir que mi familia desde que
hemos tenido la granja urbana en los
pasados dos o tres años no hemos vuelto
a tener una sola gripe en todo este
tiempo a lo mejor unos taquitos que nos
puedan hacer daño la panza pero fuera de
allí muchas cosas han sanado
te invito a imaginarte ese espacio es el
rincón ese cuarto que tienes allí lleno
de trebejos olvidados empolvándose en la
esquina de tu casa te invito ahora a
imaginar lo limpio lleno de plantas
lleno de vida lleno de animalitos
imagínate poder
e ir a ese rincón y en lugar de abrir el
refrigerador para sacar el huevo que vas
a desayunar poder levantarlo fresco
recién puesto por una gallina te invito
a imaginarte que sería de cortar la
lechuga que vas a comer en tu ensalada
el día de hoy en lugar de sacarla del
refrigerador pues todo eso que te
imaginaste hoy es posible y hoy por hoy
yo estoy convencido de que un méxico sin
hambre es esto no es una política donde
regalamos dinero a la gente para que
trate de comer para mí un méxico sin
hambre y voy a ir un paso más allá me
atrevo a decir que un mundo sin hambre
es enseñar a cada familia a poder
cultivar aunque sea una parte de sus
alimentos en casa para tenerlos
nutritivos ricos a disposición baratos y
que esa familia no tenga que estar
buscando en la basura donde alimentarse
hoy hace poco más de 20 años que
abuelita me murió sin embargo su
recuerdo sigue presente en nosotros en
cada lechuga en cada desayuno en cada
cena cada que regamos una mata o vemos
una cochinilla o una lombriz recordamos
a abuelita
hoy tú puedes hacer un cambio también te
invito a hacerlo y te invito por allí a
ayudarme a mantener viva la memoria de
una viejita de 104 años que murió
luchando por un mundo mejor
[Aplausos]